تعيش ام عمر واكثر من مئه اسره فلسطينيه
منذ سنوات مع اطفالها وسط مقبره الشيخ
شعبان ولم يشفع لها ضيق الحال حيث تلاحقها
السلطات لاخلاء المكان لجوء
طب شوفوا لنا حل على
ورق نشوي مش عارفه ايش
الحل في وضع اولويات للشعب
[موسيقى]
الحصار الاسرائيلي والوضع المعيشي الصعب
لحياه السكان في غزه زاد من ارتفاع نسبه
الجريمه في المجتمع واتخذت بعض عصابات
الجريمه المنظمه وتجار المخدرات من
المقابر مقرا لممارسه نشاطهم الاجرامي ما
يعرض حياه الاهالي للخطر يعني
كله منشطه من الناس اللي بتيجي هنا بتحششه
ولا مغزى بدهم حبه بده مش عارفه ايش بيجوا
عند القبور هنا ويجو بتخبوا وراء القبور
وبيجروا ورا الاولاد
في زلمه بيجري ورايا في السكينه بسكر
يعني الوضع الوضع هنا القعده هان بحد
ذاتها خطر هم بيجوا بالهم الاشياء بس ما
بنعرف شو بدهم مخدرات واشياء زي هيك بس
احنا بنعرفهمش احنا نفسنا
بيجوا مكممين احيانا في وجوههم
يبيع المخدرات على باب ضربك اطلع اتكلم يا
راجل اللي يقول لي سكينه اللي يقول لي بدي
احط لك شفره في وجهك اللي بقول لي انخمد
وحط راسك وما لكش دعوه في الناس ولادي
بيطلعوا يا عمي صرت اربعه الليل والنهار
اظلني على اولادي خايف بطلعهمش من قلب
الدار يا عم اياك شفت بنفسك غير هيك كما
تعون الموقفها